One Direction announced they're gonna
take a break from performing together so
they can work on their solo careers yeah
well thanks to 1d breaking up that's
what we call them there's now a huge
vacuum in the world of boy bands yeah a
vacuum that some of these smaller less
popular boy bands are now desperately
trying to fill I think some of these
other boy bands are really scraping the
bottom of the barrel but without one
direction these are the bands were gonna
be seeing bands like knocked up I don't
think that's a great band the shy boys I
mean yeah they're too shy yeah one brow
for all I don't think that's a great
yeah
Street cuties and Philip Baker hall
that's just not a good not a good
reference sugar good fern Splosion
that's not a good Bale that's just
stupid
Oh might be narcs I don't think that's a
great man Evans centipede I've never
liked them
like you don't like their music and
finally embryonic I think embryonic is a
terrible hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please